good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday we hope
everyone had a fabulous weekend it has
been a
minute since we have been back in studio
but we are here
and i'm so excited yesterday it really
does but it was a nice long weekend
and i actually like when there's like a
big space between shows like i know we
do the show every day but i feel like
sometimes there's literally no news to
report there's a lot to talk about today
on so many fronts
so many news stories so much tv recap
segments so many personal updates
so many personal updates so many life
updates there's a lot to chat about and
we're gonna get into it and
that wouldn't be have been possible if
you didn't throw your back out on
thursday yes
get into it i literally just speak in
tik-tok language sorry if you don't know
but that's a really good one oh but the
drums the drums is that
story it's not a story um but let's
definitely talk about it at some point
well let's talk about it now okay
because i think that like while people
have their hot takes on it
i feel like no one's talking about like
how suspicious it is
that like all these conversations are
being had about tick tock and
it's literally the same week that
instagram reels is like getting
um started it's rolling out like we have
it now a bunch of creators have it and i
think it's
being brought to the public in like the
next few weeks in america so
i mean no one's talking about that but
the timing is definitely suspicious like
i smell something fishy okay well there
has been conversation about tic toc
being banned for a few weeks now so
maybe that
incentivizes instagram to get their [ __ ]
together and maybe the replacement
that this country might need okay that's
more that's rational
that's rational yeah so maybe they they
were being slow about it but then they
sped up the timeline
in order to come and be the hero of the
story very possible i mean we've gotten
access to the platform it's interesting
i mean it's
literally a copy of tik tok but just not
nearly as good
there's not as many editing features and
to be honest like i've just been
uploading content so that when everyone
gets it like i'll have some content to
share
and i'm literally just taking my tick
tocks and uploading them that's always
how a new platform starts you start you
like post all content first you see
you know what what everyone's posting
what's happening there i'm sure
it will wind up being similar to tick
tock but with its own differentiators
yeah that's not how every platform
starts that's just how every new
platform that instagram steals from
other apps
starts like on in snapchat stories i was
first uploading my snapchat stories to
snapchat and instagram stories and then
i eventually just left snapchat behind
but
it just it really reminds me of the
conversation we were having last week
about igtv how it's like genuinely a
piece of [ __ ]
and that's because it was an original
idea such a genuine way it's a piece of
[ __ ]
in such a real raw and honest way it's
such a piece of [ __ ] what's so crazy is
you say that's an original
idea because yes i guess they didn't
like copy and paste
but it's actually meant was meant to
compete with youtube
oh interesting yeah well i guess when
they so like still not an original idea
when instagram steals an idea but puts
their own spin on it like igtv it is a
big fat [ __ ] failure but when they
just straight up steal like they did
instagram
stories pace and that's what they're
doing with reels like literally even you
know how when you there's a tick tock
the audio
is at the bottom and it like moves right
to left like a like a news thing
that they literally have that like it's
it's such a copy that makes me think
it's gonna be
so successful you know into a sun i mean
they're primed to be successful
right now except there is some talk
about what's going to happen with tick
tock microsoft might be buying the us
i just saw now that they have 45 days to
make a deal happen
i heard that too so tic tac might be
coming back
yeah i mean there's a conversation worth
having if
if tick tock does stick around like what
will be the future of instagram reels
like
i don't know the community is so strong
but it was on snapchat too people like
loved the platform so much but
eventually people just migrated
over because it was so much easier to
have one platform so i don't even know
if tick tock stays like what will be
yeah or maybe you know tic tac will
still be
similar to how snapchat still is
something for someone and
instagram might just be like the more
curated version of it just like how it
is yeah everything else like
my snapchat stories used to be like so
raw and
authentic right and just like fun and
then my instagram stories were really
curated and that's now all i do is just
instagram stories so i think that
instagram in general is a highly curated
place and the videos will follow suit
yeah so some of the like fashion tic
tocs that we used to see would now be on
instagram
yeah but maybe they weren't even doing
that well on tick tock to beginning they
weren't and i wouldn't mind if all the
fashion
tick tocks left because they're really
getting in the way i'm now on um
i'm in between ariana grande tick tock
and mlm tick tock where like we're
exposing mlm
okay fascinating absolutely fascinating
who are we exposing a
you know they all have weird names um
monet
monet and row like and um um
agabond or something where they give you
a free car there it's just fascinating
and there's cars there's a no but only
if you
it's like literally the top one percent
of one percent of
all the recruiters yeah um it's really
just exposing the truth behind mlms
which i thought was fascinating
but when i did long on to tick-tock this
weekend it was literally like the last
day of camp like people just crying
and like like you know when like you
were well not anymore but when we were a
kid like here's my address like write me
letters it was like here's my instagram
follow me like
it's just it's it's a little funny like
it's not because like people are really
sad about it but like the content was a
little funny i'm sorry and and
i think that the talkers will be okay
there will be a place for them whether
it's reels whether microsoft
buys tickets i think the talkers will be
okay but i'm sure it was a major blow to
the whole talk system no i mean i'm like
salty because i only have 85 000
followers i'm like yeah i get rid of
tick tock so like now my three million
instagram followers
can really be like my tick tock
followers but if i had built like a
substantial i would i would be pissed
like i agree so
i'm just salty that my tick tock never
took off
yeah but you know what [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
[ __ ] them i'm pro getting rid of no i'm
kidding i don't really care but
um i actually really like the idea of
instagram reels because it's
so for someone like me who couldn't make
it on tik tok like it's perfect yeah and
now that i had deleted tic tac a while
back when you guys send me tick tock
videos what i've realized is when it
plays in safari
i don't think the whole video plays i
think just the first 15 seconds so i've
been watching these videos being like
this isn't funny oh that's hilarious it
took me a while to realize that i wasn't
watching
the whole thing for sure and i have no
way of watching the whole thing i think
you can watch on like safari on your
computer
it's so hard for me i'm so sorry we just
got sidetracked but that was
yeah i'm so glad we were discussing a
little foreign policy so early in the
morning
yeah that's what we do here at the
morning toast we've always said it's
everything you need to know and that you
really did need to know if you're a
talker or an aspiring talker like me
right uh but there is much more to
discuss first off um
we need to talk about your back no i
want to address some rumors you know
another day another controversy for me
there has been a lot of you know
underground speculation that i
was faking throwing out my back which is
honestly hysterical and that's the kind
of controversy i can live with but it's
not unfortunately
um but i do see how someone could think
that because we canceled the show there
we had always planned on going away
thursday we were gonna do the toast with
our suitcases
ben and zach were going to pick us up
and we were going to drive we were going
to do a really early episode
but um on wednesday after our show i had
a project to shoot and i was very
excited about it and i absolutely looked
stunning like it was sickening and i was
having so much fun with this photo shoot
and they wanted theo in the photo shoot
so theo came and i was so excited i bent
down to pick them up
and i just absolutely threw my back out
literally i started screaming all these
people were surrounding me like wearing
this
terrifying and they like grabbed theo
and they put a chair and it was it was
horrible and like i was so excited i've
been looking forward to this photo shoot
it had been delayed because i've covered
and like
it we finally got it on the books and i
just ruined it like it was going so well
i ended up really being very
professional like i heard kris jenner in
my ear being like get your [ __ ] together
and i got home and i just like utterly
collapsed and i knew that if we if i had
to wake up extra early
and i was on taking muscle relaxers do
the sh i have a prescription
do the show get packed like i just knew
i didn't have it in me so i took
the responsible step in canceling
thursday's show which i apologize for
um and i really thought my back was
gonna ruin the weekend and i actually
heard that some of my sisters were
talking [ __ ] about me like being like oh
claudia's back is gonna ruin the weekend
which
when i heard really did hurt me but it's
fine that's not what we said we said we
hope claudia's back doesn't ruin the
weekend no that's what that's a part of
the conversation that you told me but i
could just imagine how you know sisters
talk and the conversation went on
i don't want to know i was deeply hurt
when i found out you guys were talking
about me but it's fine it's
fine i'm not upset i'm really not not at
all
so i'm sorry i really thought it was
going to ruin the weekend and when we
drove up there i literally was like
asleep in the car because i took another
muscle relaxer because i was in so much
pain and i just planned on really like
staying in bed the whole weekend
but like with my family so it was fine
um and really the second i got there
we had a very active weekend and i think
part of the reason my back was thrown
out was because i've literally been in
bed every single day i do the toast and
i literally get back in bed i've been in
bed for four months and
wednesday which is when i threw my back
out was my first full day at work like i
had this and then the photo shoot i
wasn't home till like six o'clock
which hasn't been the case for me in a
while but when we got there
i put on like workout clothes and we
just happened to like walk a lot we
went horseback riding we played
pickleball just what the doctor ordered
it really was and now
literally i got home and i laid in bed
all day yesterday and my back is [ __ ]
killing me okay
i got home yesterday and i was just not
right i laid in bed
all day i'm so sore i think from
horseback riding
my vagina is truly broken like my neck
yeah
my vagine no by the way literally my
neck my back
and my crack a little bit okay like i
like that the person who wrote that song
obviously when horseback riding i just
got horseback riding for the first time
in ten years
we went horseback riding in literally
one of the most beautiful places i've
ever seen in my life when we first got
there we were like
horseback riding is a good idea in
theory and we used to horseback ride as
kids but i guess
if you really don't do it a lot it's
very scary like you're very
very high up and just like anything else
the older you get the more aware you
become of all the ways that this thing
that you're doing can kill you
no i just was imagining like falling off
the horse and that wasn't even what i
was afraid of
i was afraid of the horse then stepping
on me yes that is the big issue with
falling off horses i just watched
yellowstone and it shows you all the
ways in which a horse can
hurt you so we but we did we were like
literally about to turn around but we
gave it and it's true like when you're
an adult and you like you do something
that you're afraid of you feel so
accomplished
and we ended up like walking up the
trail into like this sickening stunning
gag-worthy like corn field
gag it was seven o'clock it was like
almost sunset i literally felt so close
to god it was [ __ ] stunning
and i just love doing things like that
and ended up being like a really good
thing that i'm glad we did but by the
time we got back i couldn't feel my toes
my legs were so numb like i was in so
much pain
yeah no it's it's a full-body workout
especially when the syrups don't fit you
and as you ride through the cornfield
they become more undone
yeah like they're just like hanging
there and you're squeezing your thighs
for dear life yeah
but all worth it except that today i'm
walking like a cowboy
yeah but it was fabulous we had a great
weekend we were upstate and it was just
so great to be one with nature get out
of the city finally and
it was our first like mini staycation
with michaela which was just
absolutely everything of the sort it was
so exciting to
take her away but speaking of vacations
we have a little housekeeping news yes
i'm afraid some people are not going to
be too happy about
what we're about to say but you know it
has been a very long quarantine
and for your girls for your girls we
have done really everything we can to
like do the show every day because we
know
there's been so much uncertainty and you
can always rely on us to come here and
say stupid [ __ ] so we wanted to be that
for you we really did
and i feel like we did our jobs and we
have been we did our jobs even when it
was just
so [ __ ] hard and we are going to take
a little break but we will not be
completely gone so
starting next week jackie and i and the
steens are heading out of town
um and we will not be in studio but we
will be releasing weekly podcasts i
think we decided on every wednesday
so we're gonna be still recapping um all
the housewives that we're watching
and we're still gonna be um doing deer
toasters and the fast five stories from
that week
which actually might end up like being
really great episodes because we're not
like talking about really dumb [ __ ] that
we just like need stories for
it will just be a weekly podcast audio
only obviously plus all the patreon
episodes
yeah so it would be a great time for you
to become a patreon member it is a no
it's not permanent by any means it's
really just a hiatus
just for a month um now that michaela is
you know
ready good ready to pack her things out
of town we're gonna
get her out of here and that's what
we're gonna be doing so apologies if you
needed us in august we are going to be
taking some time for ourselves and i'm
so excited i'm so excited as much as i'm
really going to miss you guys i'm going
to miss the studio because like nothing
brightens my day like the swamp
place i'm really so excited for our
little vacation
i'm excited to see how it feels to do
weekly episodes yeah you know
it's like what other podcasters do and
they're always like running late with
their weekly episodes
i'm like how so maybe that's fine we're
gonna find out we'll definitely be late
oh for sure
yeah we will be up wednesday mornings
around 10 a.m yeah
yeah so yeah that is our housekeeping
update
it is only for a month we'll be back i
think second week of september
and it feels good you know it's the same
time the view was taking hiatus so we're
just
who are they we're just one of the hosts
everyone has gotten their hiatus
it's our turn now yeah and i feel like i
feel good about the work that we did
some of it um during the quarantine and
people needed us and i feel like we were
there for them and now it's our turn but
you have a full week of shows this week
so we're just gonna
leave it all in the studio we're gonna
spread them for you we're gonna spread
them for you like we always do
always sometimes wider than other times
speaking of things that we need to speak
about
and i can't believe we've gone on like
however long it's been without speaking
about it
snitch got a dog snitch got a dog
a snitch got a dog she has been keeping
this a secret
um she's been working on a secret
project she's been working on a secret
project uh ben and i drove her to pick a
magnolia that's her dog's name
magnolia up yesterday and it was really
emotional you know margaret was in the
car just like cradling magnolia
sobbing and it was it was big and you
know margot this is like a big step
for for someone else young snitch for a
young snitch and we feel as though it's
exactly what she needed
the timing is great since we'll all be
going away it's a great you know time to
have magnolia get to know theo have
magnolia get trained while we're all
in a house together i think it's really
good we got to spend the day with
magnolia
she is so [ __ ] cute she weighs four
pounds you i mean she literally feels
like one pound
guys she's this big you might be seeing
pictures of her i saw a few pictures of
her before i went over to snitches
and i was like oh like oh full dog
whatever this dog is
just a little handful of dogs you can
hold her truly in like your index finger
and your thumb
handful of dog she's so cute she met
theo yesterday
it did get a little tense over a bone
but i think they were just playing
it's good it's good it's good theo was
like so shook
but then so excited and you could just
see the love pouring from his heart like
that he's now
oh really i know that technically
they're cousins but he really is
stepping into this big brother role of
course and theo's kind of been waiting
for this
it's the role he was born to play it's
very exciting i mean margot you know was
up all night that's life you know with a
baby but
it'll it'll be good and and we're really
excited and happy for her on this
journey and i'm just so excited to have
another dog in the family yeah and have
another dog in the studio one day
and we've now rebranded theo's instagram
from pub with no job to pups
with no job it'll be a joint venture
from theo and
magnolia which is very very exciting we
gotta get some fabulous content for them
while we're out of town
double the premium content with the two
pups it's just it's so exciting it'll be
interesting to see how they share theo
being an only child for so many years
he hasn't had to share yet i think
that's where the conflict arose
yesterday
over the over bone gate definitely there
were some tensions and i you know i
spoke to theo after and we had a really
good
really good talk you know a heart to
heart almost um
and it's as it is with you know any only
child it's very challenging
to not only not be you know the object
of affection for everyone but to have to
now share your instagram that's
and theo works so hard he works so hard
to build that following you know over
time and just kind of like fork it over
to
you know what he says is a good for
nothing dog um
[Music]
it's hard he's entitled to his opinions
yeah but we're working through it i
think also as much as he's probably
coming out like really strong and trying
to
be so defensive like it's not just that
magnolia has come in
and stolen everyone's hearts and and
minds and instagram accounts
but also michaela came onto the scene a
few months ago and theo's just been
competing for love and attention ever
since and it's he's like
what about me can you do me a favor can
you just like not speak for theo because
you actually haven't spoken to him about
it and you were actually being like
super [ __ ] rude to me yesterday
uh i was the one being the nicest him i
gave him the most can i speak for him
like let me tell you what actually is
going on he doesn't feel any type of way
about baby michaela he is
100 supportive of her and there is
absolutely no beef with them and they
really co-existed perfectly until
magnolia sprung on the scene and just
like shook things up
yeah and i think magnolia i mean i'm not
gonna i'm just
projecting yeah i think magnolia as you
do being the same
size as michaela just makes him feel
like left out you know um no i i don't
think that's a ticking
i think it's about the sizing oh so are
you are you fat shaming my son
you said the f word are you body shaming
my son
never never he's a beautiful boy
michaela and magnolia by the way are not
the same size
they're so little both of them yeah but
michaela weights like double what
magnolia weighs it's just it's hard to
go from i can imagine it's hard to go
from being the baby to the adult
he's fine he's doing fine okay he's fine
okay he's great no he's the best boy and
he's the star of this show like
he has so much going on you know he just
has to remember that count his blessings
yeah he's fine we're fine
we're all fine okay theo like i have to
talk to him but he's
my favorite boy of all time he could
like he's a perfect angel like how could
he feel any type of way
you know maybe it would be nice if you
said it once in a while that's all i'm
saying i feel like it's all i ever say
but it's true i'll say it some more no
it's fine you know we just have to work
this is our new
our new life our new dynamic our new
normal we just have to work it out we're
going to do it and it's going to be
fabulous we have so many blessings truly
and it's fabulous it's it's really
fabulous i'm so excited for snitch i'm
so excited for the whole chapman family
it's going to be beautiful follow them
on instagram pups with no job while
you're there hitting the follow button
like you know working on your ratio
head over to jackie oh problems give her
a follow and then
at the redheads at the morning toast
fabulous new redheads episode drops on
thursday very exciting to get all the
gals together to record the episode i'm
almost done with the book it is dark
it's an intense one yeah i heard
people are talking about it yeah i i
look forward to the lively conversation
that that will ensue
fabulous well if that's all we need to
discuss anything else you wanted to
chime in with before we dive into the
past five no i feel as though it's time
to dive right in i just want to
let everyone know that my ipad showed up
today dead
dead on arrival it really happened
that's the first time it happened i know
and it's because of the long weekend
so why don't you just leave it here
charging um do you use your ipad at home
ever not really
you should think about that yeah i used
to do that maybe i'll go back to doing
that but anyway so i'll be reading off
my phone today i hope that's okay with
all of you
and without further ado it is time for
the past five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and that is true but it is monday and
since we did not have a show friday we
weren't able to highlight a black owned
business
and we want to do that today so today's
episode is brought to you by
gold founded by trinity wooford and izzy
kabory
in 2017 gold was started with the
mission of bringing good vibes to the
wellness industry
gold is an independent brooklyn-born
brand centered in making superfood
boosted essentials
for health and beauty with products that
are always natural easy
and most importantly fun gold makes
superfood health and beauty for
everybody
from latte blends to face masks they are
here to help you feel like your best
self
gold has three superfood latte blends
original matcha and cacao
and you could try it in water milk
coffee or smoothies
blend to combine with your favorite hot
or cold drinks enjoy daily at any time
all of them are vegan keto season and
there are no added sugars
to learn more about gold and to shop
their products visit gold.co that's
g-o-l-d-e
dot c-o or follow them on instagram at
gold
g-o-l-d-e thank you gold fabulousness
at every turn check it out wow that
sounds so amazing right now yeah
okay let's get into some of our great
stories first story i think the most
exciting news of the weekend
luke combs and nico hawking are married
in florida this weekend luke holmes is a
married man i'm so sorry claudia snitch
and all the ashrae girls i know no one
all the girls out there
who thought it would be them yep on
saturday the 30 year old country crooner
married fiance nicole hawking
it's hard to say her name you know i was
i'd say nico no i know because that's
like her instagram and that's what we
call her but nicole is her name
yeah sorry nicole hawking at their home
in southern florida a rep for combs
confirmed on sunday to page six
quote despite the threat of a hurricane
by the way it's hurricane season right
now um isaias is on its way so everyone
if you're in the path of the storm
please be careful
the couple had a lovely intimate
ceremony and will be celebrating with
friends and family in the new year his
rep
told page six noting that tropical storm
isaias which brushed the florida coast
on sunday
combs and hawking also posted photos
from their wedding day to instagram
he said yesterday was the best day of my
life i got to marry my best friend
i love you at nico hawking here's to
forever oh my god
i just this is so it really sprung on me
like i knew that they were engaged and i
just like never really thought about
when they were getting married because
to me they're just like otp like it
doesn't matter
and then i was just like in the car
yesterday scrolling instagram and it
just popped up and
like made my day and certain types of
things you know
like i compare this to joe jonas where
it's like when he got married like it
really it cut me deep you know
because it should have been me and with
luke holmes
you know would i marry luke combs in a
minute
but do i feel like it should have been
me no because it should be [ __ ] it
should be niko and i respect it
yeah and i i support it i also very much
respect the fact that obviously their
wedding plans are probably changed by
the pandemic and they went forward and
had we didn't see a lot of any ceremony
photos but you know
the photos of the two of them on the big
day were so beautiful like the whole
nine
she did her bachelorette party a few
weeks ago and and she found a way to
make it all
work out given the the new normal
right and i'm not a coveted bride so
maybe this is like easier said than done
but if i was i think this is similar to
what i would do like
i would get legally married in like a
small ceremony with really only the
people that
needed to be there and i would figure
out the party and i would make it like a
blowout extravaganza whenever i can
but um that's what i would do but i
guess everyone is doing it on their own
timing and
[ __ ] is real [ __ ] is real for covent
brides she posted yesterday was the most
special day i'm so happy to spend the
rest of my life with you
although we wish we could have had every
single one of our family and friends
there
we can't wait to celebrate with everyone
next year so excited to share more of
this day soon much love
fabulous i mean you just love to see
young love burgeoning love and i just
i like i'm so happy for them yeah
it's fabulous it's really fabulous the
photos are fabulous check them out at
nico hawkinger at luke homes
she looks sickening and we need to get
her instagram nick holmes
yeah that we do need to do but you did
change your name to nicole combs
on instagram which is such a sickening
nicole that's beautiful
nicole that's beautiful great time to
remind you to watch my comedy special
disgraced queen
now available on many platforms if you
head over to my instagram account girl
with no job
there's an instagram story highlight
with tons of links to places you could
watch it you could stream it
you could rent it you could purchase it
you could also stream the comedy album
like if you like listening to podcasts
you could listen to like the whole hour
15 minutes of my show as a podcast check
it out
you know what speaking of comedy albums
perfect segue into our next story
new joan rivers comedy albums are coming
in 2021 variety reports
exclusively sickening new comedy albums
from the lake jones rivers containing
previously unreleased material will be
released in 2021
production distribution company comedy
dynamics
oh my god they produced my comedy
special do you think i could get an
early uh
little uh taste get to work and i'm
literally gonna be so obnoxious and
ask announced on friday it has acquired
hundreds of hours of content from the
joan rivers estate
with plans to release a box set and
digital albums rivers rose to prominence
in the mid-1960s best known for her
quick wit
and caustic caustic style she died in
2014
unjustly and tragically and far too soon
wow this is so exciting i didn't realize
it was hundreds of hours
i mean i actually recently watched um
one of her more recent i think maybe her
last special before
she passed and it was just
everything i watched it with my in-laws
in the hamptons and it was just
like she is such a talent so sensational
what stage presence not only for like
anyone but for a [ __ ] 80 year old
like it was
whenever i can't talk about it too much
because it really makes me so sad even
though like she was 80 and like that is
when people die like that is just not
when she was meant to die
and she was truly taken from us too soon
she was at the height of her career and
if you like know a lot about her and you
know like if you watch her documentary
like
she spoke so frequently about these
highs and lows of fame and for her to go
out in a high
which is obviously great it's better
than going out in a low it's just
devastating because she had so much more
to accomplish she has so much more to
give us
and i feel as though the world her
absence is so felt like
we could really benefit from hearing
from her right now on the issues of
today
but also be nice to just hear from her
from years past
you know this is fabulous i mean like
it i whenever i think about it like it's
such a shame to me that
she like her real heyday was like not in
our time
there aren't like tons of there's not a
ton of video of her
um comedy because it was like before
specials were like
as accessible as they are now and it's
like if she was still touring right now
she would be just like banging out
comedy specials left right and center
and there's just not that many for us to
watch so this is a really
exciting announcement yes it is a really
exciting announcement
um just some good comedy news you know
there is some really good um joan rivers
content out there
the documentaries is a gift if you have
no if you haven't seen it piece of work
you will laugh you will cry i could
watch it i bought it on youtube so that
whenever i'm on a plane on my ipad it's
like downloaded
because it is just it's a roller coaster
of emotions she's so funny and she works
so hard and there's so much you don't
know about her
didn't know about her it's hard for me
to talk about her in the past tense
honestly it's really painful
it is really painful look i feel like
i'm really truly still grieving like
it's very upsetting
well hopefully this new special will
help
yeah if you ever um like want to go down
a rabbit hole
one of my favorite things to do is to
watch youtube videos of um joan rivers
getting tmz'ed like usually when she's
in the airport and so it is so
funny and then i also go down a rabbit
hole of like interviews like when she
was on howard stern
fabulous interview um just a joan rivers
also watched robin's live i think i talk
about this literally every time we talk
about john rivers
watch what happens live um put together
this like beautiful tribute she used to
go and watch happens live all the time
and in her
um in andy's book he actually said he
was working on a pilot with her
at the time that she passed which would
have been everything of the sort
um but they watch weapons i've put
together like a little collage of her
best moments on watch weapons live and
it's on their youtube channel and it's
just
it really warms the it's like all the
things i love in one place oh i'm
definitely gonna get into that tonight
yeah it's a fabulous rabbit hole to go
down and honestly if you can get it up
on your apple tv it's even better that's
the only way i can watch content because
i'm like a grandmother trying to use the
microwave i refuse to watch stuff on my
phone
i like watching stuff on my phone but i
feel you it's a different experience
today's episode is particularly hard for
me like reading off of my phone i'm so
sorry do you want to do it no no that's
okay our next story is such beautiful
and exciting news
is it the beautiful and exciting news
brought to you by legacy box yes it is
are you sure
they are the perfect sponsor for this
story because legacy box is a super
simple mailing service to have all your
video tapes camcorder tapes film reels
and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive dvd
or the cloud
i've gotten so many dm's people being
like oh i wasn't listening what was that
um
what was that company it's a legacy box
it is the most fabulous thing and
everyone needs to do it
because if your family's memories are
trapped on old camcorders
tapes or on film reels um legacy box is
a product that you need because if you
have boxes of old videotapes and photos
collecting dust in your closet or attic
it's time you get them digitized legacy
box is a way for you to easily and
affordably digitally preserve your past
the process from start to finish is so
easy you pack and send all the materials
their team digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy it
you can get back perfectly preserved
digital copies on a thumb drive a dvd or
on the cloud
it's ready to watch share and enjoy as
soon as you get it
everything is digitized by hand at their
secure 8 acre digitizing campus
they use premier scanners and playback
decks to ensure each memory is mastered
to the highest quality
plus they'll keep you up to date on the
process with regular email updates
throughout the digitizing process legacy
box is the world's largest digitizer of
home
movies and photos and has helped over
850 000 families
digitally preserve their past we are one
of those people we grew up in the
like the golden age of camcorders and
like digital cameras and we have
tons of like photos and like vcrs and we
literally used to like buy these weird
things from best buy in an attempt to
like get these videos to play
on our tv and watching them is so joyous
and it really shouldn't be that hard and
legacy box as a company is just like a
genius idea and they do the work
fabulously
and it's easy to use and it's affordable
go to legacybox.com
toast to get an incredible 40 off your
first order
if you buy today take advantage of this
exclusive offer and send it in whenever
you're ready
go to legacybox.com toast
make sure you go to that link
legacybox.com toast
to get the 40 while supplies last it's
fabulous as a gift for you know someone
in your family or just for yourself it's
really just a fabulous product
it's a fabulous product especially as a
gift that is a great idea yeah
um speaking of making beautiful memories
nikki bella gave birth to a baby boy
one day before her twin sister brie
bella also
welcomed a son into her family
alternative headline
the bella twins once again proved to be
goals at everything like what is better
than this
no there's really nothing better than
this i saw this headline and it just
warmed my heart they of course we knew
that they were pregnant at the same time
they both had sons within one day of
each other these boys are going to grow
up as twins like them
oh that's so cute like that it's really
really sweet
so nikki bella is a mom the total bella
star and fiance artem
welcomed their first child a son on
friday they said our baby boy is here
and we couldn't be happier and more in
love
everyone is safe and healthy then the
next day brie bella welcomed a son a
brother for birdie
just couldn't be more sweet like not to
make it about this i just really hope
like john cena is in a bad [ __ ] mood
about this
because he let go of a fabulous girl who
was willing to do so much for him and he
wasn't even willing to give an inch you
know
she was giving a mile and he wasn't even
giving an inch and that whole thing was
so public and terrible
and everyone really sided with brie
bella nikki bella and we just wanted her
to be happy you know
and now she's happy she's engaged and
she has a son and this is just fabulous
and honestly i hope john cena is ruining
the day he was that little stubborn
little prick
well i think john cena is doing fine for
himself and this is not what he wanted
so i think he's probably
happy that nicki got what he wanted and
that he's not a dad
but what nicki wanted was him you know i
know it's what we all wanted it's what
we all wanted like that wwe royalty like
that's what we wanted
why did they have to make it so [ __ ]
hard for us but you know what
man plans god laughs and everything
happens for a reason this everything
happens for a reason they're both in
really happy relationships
and i mean i can't imagine she's happier
than she is right now
i totally agree this is so fabulous and
it's obviously so basher which is a
yiddish word meaning meant to be
because the way that this happened with
brie is so beautiful and so kismet
and it wouldn't have happened if it
weren't for all the treachery nikki had
to endure
at the hands of john cena yeah so it all
works out all's well that ends well all
is well then
i hope they're filming the show yes it's
so interesting what's being filmed right
now
what's doing quarantine filming that's
what i was thinking when watching real
housewives of potomac last night which
we will recap in the tv recap segment
do they film the whole season do they
get stopped at some point
so judging on the time of year it seems
like this is almost exactly a year ago
it's back
to school for the kids so they must have
started filming at the end of august
and i think they probably finished the
season before we went into quarantine
but then they delayed when it was going
to premiere because oh good because they
ran out of other content right i think
and now that we're getting a new york
reunion we will most likely get a
potomac reunion in person
yeah because at least last year the
potomac reunion was in new york so andy
can come and
and we can make it happen and okay let's
just move on because i have so much to
say about potomac
okay great but fabulous news for the
bellas
family and everyone just mazel
simclas all around you'd love to see it
okay next story adele
is quote unrecognizable as she praises
beyonce's black as king
adele continues to showcase her recent
weight loss in a new social media post
praising fellow songstress beyonce
and her latest visual album blackest
king which is just everywhere
everyone's fabulous i haven't had a
chance to watch it yet but it looks
incredible
and we like we're sickened the house
down by the lion king and the whole
soundtrack and as far as i know
this is a lot of the music from the lion
king so i'm just looking forward to like
a fabulous
fierce moment you know totally she's
seen wearing the same
marine cere look as be as beyonce the
fresh face curly hair diva points to her
television while acknowledging
the queen in her saturday afternoon
instagram post writing
thank you queen for always making us all
feel so loved through your art
so it feels now like every time adele
posts instagram like the world is
shook to the core quote transformation
quote weight loss etc and like i don't
know something about the way just people
talk about this like really rubs me the
wrong way like
what i find fabulous about this news
story is like one adele's posting on
instagram which she never does
two her beyonce friendship is going
strong three she's a queen who respects
other queens like
i don't know the verbiage around like
slim down adele like
who [ __ ] cares like also i understand
you know what at a certain point like
these are celebrities when there's a
major weight loss it is news etc but she
we have this conversation every time she
posts a photo like she must be so
exhausted by this it's not like in each
photo she looks
so different from the one before right
now there was the beach one and then
there was her birthday one and now this
is the third time
birthday party one like it's just every
single time she posted no wonder she
doesn't post that much
totally it's like can we talk about
something else other than her body this
is how the adele looks now
get used to get used to it like it
doesn't have to be the title of every
story
right it's frustrating like i don't know
i couldn't put my finger on like why
this
the way people were writing about this
like made me want to roll my eyes but
that's just it it's like
get over it and stop talking about her
body like there's so much else going on
in this photo that we need to discuss
yeah her hair is curly she's not
unrecognizable she looks like a dog she
looks like a doll
yeah like i don't know something about
it like just made me like want to roll
my eyes and i couldn't figure out why
yeah i agree she looks fabulous and i'm
so glad she's happy and enjoying a good
movie on a saturday night with her
friends
i totally agree and that's the highlight
of this story yes and they have the same
shirt how cute is that right
that is that's the news do you think
they happen to have the same shirt or
beyonce sent like a pr package out
so i think at first glance i would have
thought that beyonce sent a pr package
out but this shirt
in a different color way has been seen
on like everyone duriet was wearing it
on her instagram yesterday kylie was
wearing it
um so i think it's just like the shirt
of the moment it's like a celebrity
thing yeah it's gotta get the shirt yeah
everyone's just loving the shirt
okay shirt shirt chair chair chair chair
shirt fifth and final story little happy
couple news simone biles goes instagram
official with her new
boyfriend nfl player jonathan owens i
wish snatcher was here because she is
our resident simone bile stan
but i think i speak for margaret when i
say just fabulous fabulous news
everyone's so happy what a great batch
of stories everyone's just like feeling
happy
watching good movies having babies
getting together it's fabulous what a
fabulous monday
fabulous monday simone biles has a new
boyfriend title for today's episode okay
the 23 year old olympian made things
instagram official with football player
jonathan owens on sunday
posting two photos of the pair cozying
up to one another on instagram
i get so confused by the football in the
basketball i'm like isn't he
in the bubble right now with a big smile
when is football coming back
let's talk about that in a minute okay
with a big smile on her face the houston
texans safety stood behind biles with
his arms around her while in the second
photo he leaned in to kiss her neck
quote it's just us biles captioned the
sweet snapshots
which pal nastiel yukin commented on
with a string of red hearts
this guy is very hot and i'm just happy
simone biles
is happy and with a hottie because this
is just fabulous news
but back to your question i wanted to
talk about because um
we were all together this weekend and
basketball was back and
um it was really interesting and i
wanted to hear what you to say because
we are watching the games they're all in
the bubble and there's no fans and it's
like this 3d it literally looks like a
simulation
but i found out like the screens that
are around the um
the court the court made to look like
seats with like
virtual fans are actually like real fans
like who signed up to like be on tv
that's key which is cool yeah yeah that
i was hoping it would be something like
that or
even i know that with baseball they're
putting cardboard cardboard celebrities
and stuff which is just a fun way to do
it i like the idea of doing
the fans in the stands watching it not
that i
am so big on baseball but it really did
feel like you're watching a video game
you mean basketball
sorry you know because i've ben has been
watching baseball and i think it's fine
like it really doesn't bother me they
have the sound playing
and it looks like a regular baseball
game but the whole format of the
basketball games have changed and it
totally feels like a video game yeah and
it also feels like they're playing on a
court that's too small
agreed but i guess it's i'm sure it's a
regulation there's nothing different
about the court it
it's just enclosed in it's just weird
the thing is it doesn't matter what i
think but in case anyone was wondering
like i
i it felt extreme like extremely
different yeah nobody cares but like i
hate it
yeah so i wonder how the sports fans
feel and then for football
um ben said like when we're all away
football's like gonna start to come back
so like they're also excited to like be
together and watch football so it's
coming back soon no fans um i think
it'll be fine
it's like the same it's the same field
it's just like baseball same field no
fans
and it looks it looks similar i think
okay that's scene i haven't
watched that much baseball but that
seems like a better plan of action i'm
glad that they're trying
stuff though and that there's sports
back on tv
for those who were missing it i mean the
only sport that's been on is golf
and ben has just been watching it
religiously because ben used to
literally have like a slate every night
of like a million games to watch
and now he's like one pga tournament a
week and my god it is so boring and
there's no fans
and it's so quiet and like they play the
same course four times and like tally up
the scores which makes no sense so i'm
literally watching the same thing four
times
it's just horrible it's just horrible
that's rough it's a disgrace to
entertainment
i'm so sorry well speaking of things
that aren't a disgrace to entertainment
our reality tv recap segment
which is brought to you by bruce
what's wrong with using the same old
manual toothbrush anyway
nothing at all unless you think there's
something wrong with staying put while
the world moves ahead
because while manual toothbrushes
haven't changed much electric
toothbrushes have changed the game
and nowadays there's no reason not to
get a dentist quality clean
every day meet bruce the modern electric
toothbrush that keeps your teeth cleaner
and
freezer all while being kind to your
wallet
brush is also the sound your mouth makes
while your teeth are scrubbed at 31 000
brush movements a minute
a hundred times faster than manual
brushing brush gives you a dentist
quality clean in just two minutes
without the costly markup other brands
add and with its sleek design and three
stylish colors to choose from it's one
beautiful brush that kind the kind that
makes you calm your mom and say i found
the one
with a 90-day risk-free return period
hundreds of five-star reviews and a
two-year warranty there's no need to
take our word for it
why not just try it yourself it's really
very cute and pretty and sometimes i see
like ugly ass
like bulky who wants to put that on
their counter when i have like a
beautiful marble counter but the brush
is sleek as hell and i think it's really
gonna go with some of your aesthetics
bruce has advanced features you'll love
like six unique cleaning modes smart
timer with quad pacer
four week battery life magnetic usb
power charging station
and a sleek carrying case for easy
travel and with every brush head refill
shipped bruce takes care of a mouth in
need through their one for one oral care
give back partnership with a reason to
smile so you can feel good about your
purchase
be warned a brush this good doesn't just
clean your teeth it steals your heart
if you want to get 15 off your brush kit
when you use promo code toast at
bruce.com
that's to you so b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
promo code toast again 15 off your brush
kit
only when you go to b-r-u-u-s-h.com and
use the promo code toast
if you're still using a manual
toothbrush like get with it um
it's 20 20 like what are you doing
bruce.com code toast
all right tv recap um so much let's
start with potomac it was returned
um a season premiere last night we
we love a show-stopping intro you know
where we go seven weeks earlier i love
that we really do
and so i get did you watch watch what
happens live yes i was very much in and
out of it
i watched the first half and so that
beginning teaser it seems like the fight
that gets physical is between candace
and monique and
unfortunately i think monique is in the
wrong [ __ ] well you know what
we'll see because i i have yet to see
monique in the wrong and candace in the
right
i've never yet to see monique wrong
until she pulled that bird out last
night and i was like this is disgusting
stop she's so cute she loves animals i
love her house so much i literally
i am a monique apologist like i not that
i've seen her do something that i even
need to apologize for
but i just i love everything about her
also the fact that she named her bird
t'challa from um black panther oh
so cute she is the fact that her nine
month old is potty trained is one of the
craziest things i've ever seen in my
life no and the fact that she was so
pregnant last
season and now she's just like back in
the swing of things so let's start she
starts and she goes over to karen's
house
and um karen's back in potomac i love to
see it i was really hard on karen
when i was watching the first two
seasons i i did not think that we had
ever met a more delusional housewife and
that's with knowing ramona singer
and now i no longer feel that way i feel
that she's really sweet she's a woman
who supports other women i agree
and she really likes to see her friends
do well and i think the women are
unduly hard on her agreed and like to
just catch her in you know in a lie or
like
you know catch her doing something wrong
or her business not going well and and
and they all have things like how hard
they are on her she doesn't come at them
at all and by the way she looked amazing
like for her first season was
rough with her outfits and her looks and
it was just but she really got it
together really fast when she opened the
door to let monique in last night i
thought she looked
amazing and i love her new house like
her even her original house
had like no furniture in it and it was
so weird and it was like nice and big
but it was just it was just that it was
just big like yeah there was nothing
there was no it looked like no one lived
there it looked like a model home with
like
stage furniture i really like this house
i thought it was beautiful
i'm not 100 sure like what's going on
with her finances but it's kind of like
a derek kemsey situation like i just
don't want to know like
keep the looks coming keep the house
coming and i won't ask any questions i
actually feel like her finances are fine
from what it sounded like
ray had a tax issue that he had to pay
back and that he paid it back but he
still has his business and he's doing
fine and now she
is a housewife she has her business and
i think they're doing they're doing fine
and so i'm happy to see her back in
potomac well i thought it was really
interesting how she like immediately
like she opened the door and she just
started opening up about her how her and
ray are going through things
and monique was right like she's not one
to really like divulge on things like
that so if she's
at the pro at the point of telling
monique on camera like it must be bad
yeah it must be like she has made a
decision and now she's
making it look like she's on her way to
the decision yeah i thought that was
very interesting because you know
they've their marriage is an institution
like they've always kind of been like
this
like the older stable institution in
potomac and i really thought that was
worrisome
yeah or she just is turning a new leaf
of being open on the show yeah maybe she
feels now
four seasons in that she can trust the
show and and
share more with the viewers so even if
she's not necessarily getting divorced
like
she just wants to be open because i
think by now she probably has a lot of
really good positive reception from the
show yeah
and it's a two-way street you know last
night's episode was really hard for me
because i had a major realization
and it's hard for me to say because i
love her so much but giselle has
terrible style
both her outfits that black hat she was
wearing with a tiara on it
and then her new blingy home um it was
devastating for me because she's really
my
my favorite and i'm a gizelle apologist
and i could not apologize for that
couch or those bar stools or literally
anything in her new house the outside
was cute
the inside was literally just a travesty
yeah that was wild
the decor and like production wanted you
to feel that way about it
i actually liked the bar stools on their
own i hated but
the decor was something else okay and
that purple couch i had like bling in it
which she also sat in on watch dragons
live and like get this couch out of here
no it's perfect for watch what happens
live because it's like fun it's like a
set couch
it's not a living room yes it's like
it's perfect like if you have like an
office
like kim zolciak has like the craziest
office in our house and it has literally
our thrones
yeah that yes i agree but like for a
living room couch in a sitting area a
formal sitting area it's absolutely
terrible
yeah and that was hard for me yeah that
that is hard
and i guess i never really noticed it
but that
coupled with like her outfits and like
that
that baseball hat that had a tiara on it
like it just triggered me that hat was
really bad but i feel like in past
seasons
she's had good style i don't know
now i'm just really aware of it yeah and
i did not like what she wore to the
denim and diamonds party because she
only wore diamonds
what was she wearing again oh the it was
like bomb on ask yeah yeah it was just
like a little
costumey you know what i'm realizing her
her style isn't blingy it's costume
yeah but also that theme was just no
literally
candace had those boots and had that
dress and wanted to wear them both so
she came up with a theme called diamond
and denim
and i didn't even i liked both of her
things separately i did not like them
together candice
like never ceases to disappoint with the
most boring storylines like
the most warning one anniversary one
year anniversary party like
making like the dessert i just i'm so
bored by it i was bored by her wedding
planning i was bored by her dragging
her mom um through therapy and making
that her storyline i'm just i was bored
by all of it and i was bored by last
night's storyline too i don't know what
her storyline for this season's going to
be but if it's about like her financials
that it's like when she started talking
about money again and like really like
you
you're spending twenty two thousand
dollars on a party even though she
didn't end up spending that because that
was for the full bar and to
honestly to invite people over to a
party for a cash bar when you run it in
a crowd like potomac
it's a disgrace and just have it have it
at a bar where you can afford it i'm
sorry yeah have it at your husband's
restaurant or a house
yeah like i that was just that was not
going to work for me no that was not
going to work for me either and
i'm disappointed that we didn't get a
statement from karen hugor on her side
yeah well she's kind of toned it down
since she used to do that you know
for sure but there's a time and a place
and and that was the time and the place
what i found very interesting was that
giselle's kids were not like
at all thrilled that their parents were
back together i know i found that to be
very interesting it's clear that they
really took the mom's side
in the divorce because they know that
their dad cheated on their mom
but i feel like it's a kid's fantasy
like your parents like
every kid of child of divorce dreams
that their parents are gonna get back
together and they almost
never do and they like hate it i know
she has such good kids they're so sweet
i love they're so sisterly
and it's it's
like it's almost funny they really like
roast her on tv all the time
yeah and they have such a great
relationship with her and i'm sure that
if there was really
a real issue she wouldn't be showing
that agreed um but
i look forward to andy said i'm watching
himself that throughout the season it
doesn't get much better with the girls
being into the relationship
but hopefully like by now but
automatically happens live they're
she said they're still together yeah but
and so the proof is always in the
pudding
a hundred percent i don't know how it's
going to work like if he like
permanently lives in atlanta and she
can't leave potomac she's a star you
know
but maybe that's for the best like
totally speaking of relationships that
aren't going to work out
robin's storyline again being like are
we getting married are we not like
and was i supposed to be moved by that
scene in the kitchen where she was like
we need to get married
like beg him tonight yeah and he's like
we need to grow as a couple it's like
you've been together for 30 years like
what growing do you need to do i don't
know if i was supposed to like
get teary eyed at that but i actually
didn't no i did not
with robin it's been the journey because
the first two seasons i was like
why does she keep getting her contract i
know last season i was like
wow she's a great addition to the bunch
like she's so fun she's so um
like laid back it's refreshing but now
this season i'm going back to season one
where it's like why am i watching this
again no i i know that you don't like
her and for some reason i've just like
had a spot for her in my heart i just
really like her friendship with gisele i
think that's what it is
but it's like when we opened up and
she's in like the same house with the
same conversation and the same
everything it's like
where's the growth i i have no idea also
yeah speaking of her friendship with
giselle it is always so nice on the show
to have like two people who you know
won't betray each other because
it's just like this constant and it's
not an arrangement of uncertainty no
totally it's not like a lisa vanna from
kyle richards that wasn't a friendship
that was an arrangement yeah this is a
friendship yeah and so like
when last season candace and monique are
sisters and then
they're she's going to drag her i can't
depend on that
but i can depend on robin and giselle
and i appreciate that and it's important
in a franchise
yes for me the hardest part of the
episode was seeing um charisse
at the party because like i i just don't
[ __ ] with her like at all
she bothered me a lot on her on her time
on the season
mostly because she came on the show just
like roast her husband and like just
don't do that like do that in private
you know
and i just i never got with her and now
monique is isn't [ __ ] with her like
i'm not either because she's talking
[ __ ] about monica monique wouldn't even
say
what she's been talking [ __ ] about her
because it's like why breathe life into
it charisse isn't going to get a
testimonial so no one needs to
why is monique going to tell millions of
people right now when only
probably sharice's however many twitter
followers heard it and it is very
interesting that this
i forget i think maybe it was monique or
karen pointing out like why is cherise
at this party like her and candace don't
even know each other
makes me think like coupled with cherie
is now like talking [ __ ] about me it's
like her an attempt to get back on the
show but that she's been doing she's
been doing that every season she's been
part of the storyline when she brought
sherman's ex-wife yes you know she's
always trying to like stir the pot she
annoys me like a lot yeah
she and the camera like production does
not give her the time of day it's like
in beverly hills they let anyone just
like walk on and like take a dump in the
middle of the set like they don't care
if you've been on the show like you can
now come
to any place camille grammer's literally
been around for the last three seasons
but they just do not let shuri's back in
and honestly it's hilarious
it's hilarious um wendy the new girl
um her like moment with monique being
like i have a two four or seven the six
month old
like i'm nigerian i'm 35 like i just i
literally was gonna cry like it was
beautiful yeah but then that's exactly
what
monique did when she met candace and
like that's just her way of
relating to people is like realizing all
the things that you have in common i
liked wendy right off the bat i think
she's gonna be a great addition me too
and they gave us a great sneak peek at
not next week but like the whole season
and wendy really can hold her own
that's dr wendy you address me properly
like that was everything of the sort
they go to portugal and last night's
episode really got me thinking because
before they premiered the new episode
they were playing the reunion so i just
like was watching it
and it was really just so elevated and
so glamorous really reminding me of
beverly hills
and i spent the whole day yesterday
catching up on new york and beverly
hills which we'll dive into a little bit
um and i was really thinking about how
like the difference in the the new york
trip they're all on the trips now
between the trip that they're taking on
beverly hills to rome where everyone is
like
literally sickening outfits chanel
chanel kyle's spending eight thousand
dollars lisa spelling four thousand eric
and jane spelling four thousand
sun setting four thousand like all of
that compared with like the new york
women who they've all been on for the
same amount of time
to watch those two episodes which i did
last night back to back
eye opening eye opening we'll get into
it i just want to say we had we didn't
talk about ashley
oh darby she was boring she was invited
to the party but she has a baby and i'm
happy for her baby's really cute and
she i sometimes i have like visceral
reactions to her and she didn't bother
me she's fine yeah i know you you
probably i like her more than you i do i
think because i just
i like her personality i don't like when
she like just stirs [ __ ] up just to do
it
but i like her commentary and i think
she's funny and i'm liking the
friendship between her and monique i
mean any friend of monique is a friend
of mine
that no 100 she's a good um
like a people reader so you just follow
her yeah blindly
um so let's just get into new york
really quickly it was not
um a good episode actually it was fine i
like when they go on trips
and they actually wherever they they
always go to like mexico
turks and caicos they really do like
tropical mostly and because they always
film in the winter and i always want to
go where they go like this house in
cancun was sickening
thickening what's crazy though is that
there's only five of them and the
cast feels so small because it's just
like
ramona sonia dorinda leah luanne and
we're so familiar with all of them that
there's no like why wasn't a lease on
the trip i thought the same you know
just to throw in like something
different because all these people are
mainstays now so
to ostracize one of them on a trip is
less exciting
because it's like oh we have to watch
you like re you know
yeah may all make up too the episode was
difficult for me because
really when it comes to the birthday
party thing i think i'm on team ramona
yeah so as people i'm on team leah when
it comes to the birthday party we talked
about this last week
i am team ramona because it is ramona's
birthday party and so
she even though like being 63 years old
and having this
birthday is you know judging and silly
and whatever like
she is entitled to want what she wants
um and the thing about the vagina they
showed a clip
well so the reason why i think i'm more
firmly as it relates to the birthday
party on ramona's side
after watching this episode is they
showed us footage we didn't see on the
first time i saw
butt cheek her dress was above her hips
right which means that on the front side
there would be vagina 100
and you know what with the grinding and
it wasn't appropriate i do think ramona
singled out leah a little bit like
sonia was being just as much of an
animal as leah was and i think ramona
there's probably something about leah
that ramona doesn't like
and ramona went after her more than the
other girls but leah's behavior
was unacceptable in in that type of
situation and ramona said that she's
like if you want to do that here in the
house in cancun
go for it we're alone but it was it was
a dinner it wasn't a party
and there wasn't a dance floor they were
on a couch it was inappropriate i'm
sorry to be so
like prude but it was inappropriate
given the setting
and when they all went to that
hairdresser event which actually was
like so nice and like luanne so nice
luanne's charity work sometimes comes
off like so
no but it's last week and this week i
was impressed by the
beautiful thing that she did her
humility like i really was and and i
really
enjoyed it and the women were acting
like animals and not one person except
ramona
even engaged with the women who were
there to get haircuts and that really
bothered me and i was surprised that
luanne didn't say anything lens just
kind of staying out of everything but
the women were acting like animals at
that hairdressing event and not even
addressing
the beautiful thing happening in front
of them yeah and i was surprised the way
i didn't say anything when it comes to
the party
i agree with ramona but now ramona has
taken it to another level that she
cannot come back from
her talking about leah's mental health
and medication
and drinking and making all of these
assumptions assumptions about her and
talking about it with the other women is
just so unacceptable
now it's become a much bigger issue that
of course it didn't need to be when it's
just
about misbehaving at a party right no it
was it was like a tiff and now it's like
you really can't be on ramona's side
not only because of that but like this
happens every season when they go on a
trip
i just am appalled by the way ramona
talks to the staff
and literally when she walked in she was
like wow look at all these servants i
was like
did you just say servants i thought
maybe she said service
but i rewinded and according to my
instagram people agreed that she's
definitely successful
insanity like who [ __ ] speaks like
that and just like throwing i want this
in london can you steam it like just the
way
she speaks to staff on every trip like
really rubs me the wrong way and this
is no exception and it was hard for me
because in the beginning of the episode
i was kind of
on her side and by the end of it you
just couldn't be no
you just couldn't be and so i watched
that right after i watched real houses
beverly hills and
same it's a shame that we didn't do an
episode last week because it was the
episode of this bravo bravo [ __ ]
bravo
the tide has turned we're getting all
the information
first of all this roam trip just looks
so utterly fabulous and like
to watch this episode now in month for
going on
five of quarantine where like it's just
it's it's hurtful yeah it's hurtful to
watch this fabulosity to know that
that's what's out there in this world
and like
we can't have any part of it i felt
really overwhelmed like during the
entire episode because i knew this thing
was coming at the end but not all the
women were there and they came in waves
you know it was like the first wave
segment then sudden came
and it was it was overwhelming honestly
because there was so much glamour like
all their looks even just going to get
drinks they all looked amazing
i'm not gonna lie some of garcelle's
looks were really questionable but i
won't
she got there late so like i won't and
denise was just
there's no excuse for those boots just
absolutely horrible um but for the most
part the group really looked sickening
the house down yes
and i just kept feeling like every time
they would walk down to dinner i just
was i was literally overwhelmed like by
the sequin blazers like everything it
was too much yeah and like i feel like i
didn't get enough
of a full shot of everyone's looks you
know especially erica the first night
like i wanted i wanted more information
on what was she wearing like i got to
reits
i got the look sickening i got her
versace look the next night
amazing i loved what she wore to the
steps
um i love what eric loves war
ii it's really just the two of them you
know yeah and you know kyle kind of like
basic style it's pretty but she always
knows how to dress for occasion but it's
not
reinventing the wheel no not at all and
rena always looks totally appropriate
and fun and chic
and young yeah um and she always looks
great she's a great addition to the mix
but it's really just erica
and dory holding it down for all of us
and i'm sure some people find it to be
so frivolous what they're doing but like
it's not like if they weren't on a
television show they would not go to
dinner dress like this but they are
they're giving us television not only
that like they go on these trips
because they dress the way that they do
and they go shopping like the women in
new york
when they go shopping they go to like a
hotel gift shop and spend two hundred
dollars like these women literally
who spend eight kyle spent eight
thousand dollars like
that is what you have to put that out to
get that back like
no the women not every franchise goes on
a trip like this and it's because the
women of beverly hills are consistently
keeping it out of 10 and i do think some
other franchises could really take notes
i agree they didn't tell us how much
street spent though which um
was concerning but you know who's also
bringing looks and has her own glam
sutton
and i really appreciate it she does it
from a much more like reserve she's not
so
daring with her looks but she always
looks beautiful she has her own glam so
i think her
erica and dorit are the ones who brought
glam right yeah well because kyle's
always like judging everyone for their
glam but it looked like she
had glam but me i think she's gotten
really good at doing me too
and so maybe there are some other hair
and makeup people like floating around
but i think
those three brought their own and then
and sometimes production brings for
everyone or like the hotel
salon or something yes um now let's talk
about bravo bravo [ __ ] bravo because
i feel
i feel two ways i feel as though brandi
is 100 telling the truth and i don't
think that should be
a question i think the question is and
honestly sutton brought it up in
a real way if if you think about it i
know it's like trashy tv but in a way
teddy and the girls really outed denise
um
and when they brought it up she was
obviously denying it because it's a very
difficult thing
conversation to have especially when
you're on tv and especially when you
have kids and a husband
and i don't know what their arrangement
is but it did feel like
it didn't like teddy could have aired
her grievances
with and she was teddy was obviously
really hurt by what she heard denise say
about her
and i think she could have had a
constructive conversation with her
without bringing that up and i don't
know the whole thing felt
it didn't feel good no it didn't feel
good i have a lot of different thoughts
about it
but first of all teddy felt like she had
to say because it was already out there
but if teddy and kyle agreed to never
mention it brandy's conversation would
not have been aired that part of it they
would have cut it out completely because
it's not a story line it didn't go
anywhere
and even though they they're not so
close with denise and they don't need to
protect her like
they each have something on the show
that they don't talk about
they they all stay above the line with
one another and they just went
completely below
the belt with denise about this like one
they're outing her too like imagine
it's you're telling everyone and her at
the same time that like
accusing her of having an affair
cheating on her husband like and she has
to
address it with cameras there and in
front of all of these women like
that it's just so uncalled for
especially when you know even when like
dorit and camille were fighting last
season and camille brought up her money
troubles everyone was like whoa
yeah right but this is so much more
serious than that agreed and they just
felt it was okay to go there and so i
think sutton handled it so well when she
was like are you more concerned about
what denise said about you or about
denise and brandy and what i found to be
very interesting was that sutton then
corroborated the story saying like yeah
i heard it too but i never brought it up
and sutton was completely right and
she's like i know i'm new and i might
not have you know
any ground to stand on but i agreed i
think that the way the women handled the
information from rarity was
awful was really awful and i think that
if
they not that they it's not on them to
like care about niece especially when
they've just heard what she said about
them but like
it's just the personality of the show
that this the beverly hills has never
had to go
so there like there to
bring up something so personal for one
of the women and they could have had
like a
crazy conversation about all the things
that he said to brandy and it could have
been left at that and so
teddy thinking that she's doing denise a
favor by bringing it up like you're not
doing anyone any favors
now i have a few questions that i'm
curious about i'm sure that
the women say bravo often yeah and i
want to know who has said it
other times and when yeah um because
denise said it the other night at dinner
and we never even heard it they cut it
out so seamlessly
right and what is the the legal
reasoning behind that why can't you say
bravo no so i don't think it's a legal
thing but it's like
it's like saying hello we're filming a
tv show and i'm breaking the fourth wall
right now so when you say bravo it's
like calling out the thing right
and they wouldn't air that because it
makes it too much of a tv show but right
in this moment like
real life and television are we try to
give her a heads up she's like honestly
like what you're doing like they're
obviously it's like when theresa was
like they better cut this
when they were talking about um yeah her
si her telling uh danielle stabbed to
pull margaret's hair
like of course they're gonna use that
and honestly you freaking out about it
makes it more of a spectacle and they're
of course going to use the footage yeah
but then i also think that bravo kind of
did set a bad precedent when they paid
denise so much money
for two seasons and they basically said
to her like you're indispensable you
we want you on this show so badly like
it's your rules
sort of you know someone who's coming in
and has to prove themselves needs to go
through
all of this [ __ ] to earn respect to earn
respect but like she just came in
at the top and it's kind of a tough
precedent to step because it lets denise
think that she gets
say over what gets aired and what
doesn't because she's they're so happy
to have her there right but at the end
of the day once you sign that contract
like you're signing your life away like
you have
really no editorial
rights yeah and so now i feel like as
much as
before was like oh my god is it true is
it not true
i don't i don't care it's not my
business
right now i feel like teddy and kyle
they are the bad guys in this story
i agree it was very poorly handled
and it made me really sad like i've
actually never seen denise cry and she
like got teary-eyed because it's
like it's not about whether or not it's
true it's just about like
she was technically outed and that's
really [ __ ] up on tv in front of a
group of people like terrible
yeah i i don't i'm not here for it i'm
not here for it either but i also see
and recognize brandy being hurt
but i don't know why brandi had to go on
tv and say it yeah
there's a lot going on here but without
brandy being a full-time cast member it
just
it doesn't feel like obviously everyone
this is what everyone wants to see but
it also it just also doesn't feel
relevant
yeah you know if everybody's just coming
in with all their allegations against
people at the table
i'm going to walk in and start saying
and also it's like i'm sure denise said
all those things to brandy about the
women
yeah but like i feel like in this group
it really is like a
isolated thing where it's like you're
only responsible for the things you do
instead
inside
the group when you want to talk to your
real friends your camp friends
right outside if you're friends and you
want to be real with them like it's so
difficult to be held accountable for all
of that when this is just like
agreed small world that you're living
and it's meant to be like real life but
it's like a simulation what goes on in
the simulation
it is a simulation like i'm sure if you
know faye
showed up and mentioned everything that
kyle ever said about the women to all of
the women
i wouldn't even care what it was because
like of course kyle's opinion is about
her co-workers
totally and it's it shouldn't be fodder
for hr yeah
agreed um but it was a fabulous [ __ ]
episode it was
it was it had everything everything so
let's wrap up our tv recap segment with
if beale street could talk yes
um which was our toast movie of the week
and you know what it was not my favorite
it wasn't my favorite either i had a
really high expectations because it was
so
critically celebrated critically
acclaimed nominated for a lot of awards
and um i just i wasn't crazy about it i
thought it was a good story but just
like the way it was filmed
was just like not my favorite style also
you told me that it's not a true story
so when it ended i was waiting for my
black and white text which is my
favorite part of a movie
and most of the movies we've watched
recently unbeknownst to me were based on
true stories or loosely based on true
stories
um and we got no black and white text so
i just did like the smallest bit of
research
and it's an adaptation of a novel the
story itself like this particular man
and this woman didn't necessarily exist
but i think it's meant to be like
this could be anything like there's some
relation of stories like that
there are so many stories like this but
then it really harkens back to a
conversation we had on the show a while
ago about hunters
which is like they made up um a story uh
a terrible story
about something that happened in the
holocaust which ended up not being true
when it's like at the end of the day
there are so many worthy stories stories
worth telling
about the holocaust and same for what
it's like you know in the 70s for a
black man in america so
i don't know i didn't i was confused by
a lot of it it's like if beale street
could talk is in louisiana then it takes
place in new york
and beale street again is like it's not
necessarily about louisiana it's this
it's everyone lives on beale street that
was the quote in the beginning and i got
it
just a lot of a lot of things about it
confused me um
i liked the love story a lot i feel like
you could really feel the love between
tish and fanny and like honestly the
scene where
tish and her family told fanny's family
about the baby was the best scene in the
whole movie i mean
tish's sister like that's me like i i
just i
loved it and it was it was fascinating
and i thought it was like really one of
the most
like polarizing scenes in the movie and
there were things i liked about the
movie like regina
king is everything of the sort and i
needed more of her and i didn't know
what was gonna happen so it's like when
she went down to puerto rico i'm like oh
we're saved like yeah regina king can do
everything
and she's gonna save us and she couldn't
no i
just assumed that that was what was it
was gonna be a hard conversation but
eventually you know it would justice
would be served and justice was not
served and i think that was a really
powerful message to end on where it's
like
you know things don't just work out no
they usually don't in situations like
this
yeah that was really tough i agree i
felt the same way and then i was just
like no this is the reality of the
situation
yeah it was i don't know and then just
like to go through that journey and then
to find out that it wasn't based on a
true story
when there's a million stories like it i
just i didn't see the point
in like fictionalizing it or non-fig
whatever yeah no
i agree that's kind of how i'm feeling
right now about the redheads book and i
think that's a similar conversation that
we're gonna have
yeah um so
i i agree but it was really well done
i'm glad that i saw it because it there
was so much
talk about it yeah it was good so i
highly um
recommend it i enjoyed it but it's like
when you know we're talking about like
hidden figures like
when we're comparing it to other movies
that we watch it just wasn't my favorite
i agree
um but anything to support regina king i
just love her so much um so for next
week's trust me of the week we are not
going to do a toast movie of the week
because we are
out next week so that's that on that for
a little bit but
again for august starting next week we
will just be doing
weekly episodes every wednesday i'm
still doing dear toasters all of our
housewives recaps and of course the fast
five stories that you need to know from
the previous week
and it'll be great thank you guys for
giving us that time to
break a little bit and i'm very much
looking forward to that anything else
you want to say before we
wrap it up no i believe that is all she
wrote she's been writing a lot today so
i think she'll be grateful for the break
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the monday morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast every weekday monday
through friday on youtube
and we are also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcast find us the morning toast and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
we hope you guys have a fabulous day and
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
goodbye